okay and his first Network TV interview
the Dominican Republic's top health
official tells CBS News the recent
deaths of American tourists are from
natural causes at least eight Americans
have died on expectedly in that
Caribbean nation this year alone but the
dr's Health Ministry of Health says
Americans fears of traveling to the
island are unfounded mola legi is in the
capital at Santo Domingo mola what do we
know about these cases
well good morning Tony the Health
Minister here in the Dominican Republic
told us that the autopsies for nearly
all of the deceased that here on the
island show that they all had at least
one previous health issue that led to
their deaths but the families of the
Americans who have died here remains
skeptical is it frustrating that your
tests that your doctors are being
questioned no I
health minister dr. Rafael Sanchez
Cardenas insisted to CBS News that there
is no connection between the eight
American deaths this year in the
Dominican Republic
estamos hablando what are we talking
about Sanchez Cardenas told us a group
of patients who come with a morbid
condition prior to vacationing in the
Dominican Republic and have died in the
country as tourists die every year in
all countries
Sanchez Cardenas explained the autopsies
of several of the Americans to us he
says all of them had at least one
pre-existing condition from obesity to
hypertension to an enlarged heart to
alcohol or tobacco problems some friends
and family members of tourists who have
recently died in the dr refused to
believe it is all merely a coincidence
56 year old Vittorio Caruso died on June
17th
Bruce Hicks was his friend I hope
whoever is in charge over there is
getting some interest because
you know what Americans want to go over
there after all that's gone on you know
human nature is to blame something CBS
News medical contributor dr. David agus
says tourists deaths in the Dominican
Republic are no worse this year than in
the past but that the chance of death
can in fact rise while on vacation you
take risks you do activities you
wouldn't do otherwise normally you're
sitting behind a desk all day and
vacation you go climb a mountain you
jump off a cliff you go swimming all day
that's a lot of stress
Sanchez Cardenas says Americans have
nothing to fear
Kathy Na Nog adam pls say woody that
absoluta the dominican republic has the
guarantee of absolute security he told
us in the country's top tourism official
francisco javier garcia had the same
message what do you say to the American
tourists who have concerns about coming
here kaki no tane Melissa Dorsey on that
here we do not have this situation of
mysterious deaths he says there is no
avalanche of death US officials to date
have also made no connections between
any of these deaths
the FBI is conducting toxicology reports
on three of the deaths that happen back
in May at the Bahia Principe resort
chain those reports are expected back
sometime in the next two weeks and
Anthony as you can imagine families back
in the states are eagerly awaiting those
results but they are Imola Lengai and
the Dominican Republic thanks it's a
pretty peculiar coin to have ten people
who have died in the same location and I
understand what David agus was saying on
vacation you take risk but in a couple
of cases they went to the minibar you
know it wasn't that they were out there
doing something that was dangerous it's
concerning if the numbers going down you
can understand the outrage if you are in
the Ministry of Health in the dr was an
explanation on the other hand if paid if
eight or ten deaths is the the lower
number than usual then whoa what's a
usual year would like to see their
toxicology